remember when Holly told you about the
post for the film I mean do you member
where you were and what you're thinking
I was actually at home playing massive
and then she emailed it to me and I was
so excited about it okay and was there
ever a chance that maybe you weren't
going to submit was there any kind of
close call where you just didn't come
close to submitting more or you guys are
good to go with it no we always had
planned to submit Holly did it before
any of us had the chance to she was like
hey this is what we're doing and I
already submitted so we're like cool and
is tank your first work with a an
articulated hat and what do you pull
that sort of articulation it's
animatronic this is what it's called and
i believe it's his first animatronic
head that he's helped make but he's
always been really good with like
fiddling with things and figuring
electronics out so it wasn't too much of
a task for him well Holly had mentioned
that she's had offers even though the
film hasn't been released to the general
public have things change for you to
have you had offers from production
houses or with with Holly we all we all
still work together oh wow I'm gonna go
with you as its yeah we're we're a team
we'll always have been a team and we're
gonna stay a team very nice oh we all
work together are you moving from San
Bernardino or you're gonna dump someday
we'd like okay right now we're just
commuting which is fine holly has a very
comfortable futon that we own ring with
please stay on good
you